it has like this like smoky flavor I
don't know where it's coming from but uh
it's kind of nice
Oh smoke flavor added my name is rameen
I'm a teen I'm Ricardo I'm a teenager my
name is Mandy I'm a former teacher and
I'm Vanessa I'm a teacher today we are
going to be eating some Lunchables
I actually remember when Lunchables
first came out and that was probably the
last time that I've had them Pizza
lunchable was the one that I remember
the most
I don't know if I necessarily liked it
but I ate that all I eat it all the time
to be honest I'm a little uncomfortable
with like shelf-stable meat and cheese
that's okay to kind of have in your
backpack all day but we'll do it let's
get it started we have these nacho
Lunchables or if you prefer this view
this is kind of bougie I feel like these
are way cooler than when I have kick hat
in the chips there's the cheese I'm
guessing this is salsa but it just seems
to be like tomato liquid that's not bad
I mean it's not good but it's not bad
it's not as bad as I thought but I think
I'm gonna just eat the kick head I would
have to throw in something healthy with
this I feel like just this by itself is
like non okay meal the haricot have to
have like maybe a bag of chips I like to
be healthy I'd be sad if this is my
lunch as a child yeah what did I do
overall meal probably a seven I'm gonna
give it a four yeah - yeah I know
there's better Lunchables
I would never get this I just feel like
the Hispanic and me it's like really
offended by this yell well to be quite
honest I feel like I can't get worse
than so weird yeah I think this is the
worst one to be honest
onward and upward we'll see where we
have alright so Turkey and American
cracker stackers with an Oreo it claims
to be a good source of protein
definitely it probably comes from that
Oreo but now that I opened it again I
just had all these like nostalgic
memories and feelings come of like I
can't with this collar ever I would
prefer cheddar or Gruyere but that's
asking a lot of them out of a lunchable
[Music]
the crackers a flop just saying live one
suppose you need to work on that I think
it's better than the nacho cheese I have
like this like smoky flavor I don't know
where it's coming from but uh it's kind
of nice
oh it smoked flavor added I just I can't
vibe with it and I'm really disappointed
in myself for that oh okay you know what
this just got another number and rating
it just went up one six I would bump it
up to a five I'm gonna get it a five and
a half yeah I'll give it a six they're
famous Lunchables pizza I can't say that
I've had this one before
you feel like you're cooking what you're
actually not build our own pizza wait
there's definitely not enough cheese for
three pizzas super authentic it's
totally a pizza use it 200
you're rationing your pepperoni though
oh and you made a smile
I was thinking I'm not gonna say but it
just reminds me of stealing people's
Lunchables pizza when I was a child
yeah as a kid I remember being super
excited about these and they're like the
most delicious things that has a weird
aftertaste I mean it doesn't taste like
pizza but it's kind of its own thing
like it's it's the Lunchables pizza this
one doesn't come with a dessert are you
kidding me that's so real I would rate
it a 4 I think I'm gonna go with another
5 and a half I think it was the
equivalent of the ham and cheese all
right that's the end of the lunchable
experience my favorite was definitely
the nachos again I was slightly offended
as a Hispanic but overall it was a good
experience I think my favorite one was
the turkey stackable my favorite were
the cheese and crackers
deckers I think it's just because I like
say that my favorite was the cracker
stackers it has a really cool name I
think the only time I would eat a
lunchable is if one of my nieces or
nephews are eating them and I just like
steal one from them but I wouldn't buy
my own I don't think I would ever go out
of my way like I would never go to
Ralph's and be like I need Lunchables
the sweet I think that today's
Lunchables were probably my last unless
there's some sort of catastrophe
[Music]
you